[Music]
take two points on a circle and draw a
line straight through the space which
was encircled is divided into two -
these points out a third one which gives
us two more chords the space through
which these lines run has been figured
into four continue with the fourth point
and three more lines drawn straight now
the count of disjoint region sums in all
to eight a fifth point and it's four
lines support this pattern gleaned
counting sections one Divine's that
there are now 16 this pattern here of
doubling does seem a sturdy one but one
more step is troubling as the 6th gives
31 wait what
1 2 4 8 16 31 what's going on here
why does the pattern start off as powers
of 2 only to fall short by one at the
sixth iteration that seems arbitrary why
not 1 2 4 8 16 32 64 1 to 4 8 15 if you
keep going the number of sections
deviates even further from powers of two
except when it hits 256 but this just
begs the question of what the pattern
really is and why it flirts with powers
of 2 in my next few videos I'll explain
what's happening which will include one
of my all-time favorite proofs but
interesting problems deserve to be
shared pondered and discussed before
their secrets are hastily revealed so
while I work on animating my explanation
I encourage you to think of your own to
be clear the question is this if you
take some set of points on a circle and
connect every pair of them with a line
how many pieces do these lines cut the
circle into does it matter where these
points are and why does the answer
coincide with powers of two for fewer
than 6 points
[Music]
you